do you have any advice for writers on
getting the career they most want the
writing career and then first off how do
they even know what that looks like yeah
so I want to I want to relay something
that my favorite is when the smartest
agents ever what she said when she came
to my UCLA class so step one ask
yourself if I if I was guaranteed
success absolutely guarantee success
doing anything as a writer what would I
be doing and I want you to be specific
so don't say I want to write features do
you want to write Academy
award-nominated winning features do you
want to be writing directing small
interpersonal movies do you want to be
writing big popular culture successful
movies everyone's talking about
don't say I want to be doing 60-minute
TV what kind of system and be very
specific and what I really urge people
to do is for this exercise don't
constrain yourself by what you think is
possible like if you're like I'd love to
be i'd love to create comedy shows but I
don't know if I'm funny enough well the
answer is if you were guaranteed success
what would you be doing and why and I
think that's a question writers should
ask themselves at least twice a year and
and anyone who's newer to this this
journey absolutely something to ask
yourself in you know I think part of
your question was well if someone's new
and inexperienced enough maybe they're
not entirely sure that's okay just write
down today what your answer would be
your answer can change over time as you
get more experienced the more education
but know what it is that you most know
what you would do if you were guaranteed
success and then the agent said now hear
me when I tell you nobody gets the
career they want you get the career you
deserve so the key is figure out the
career you most want then figure out how
to deserve that career and I'll get
there in a second but I just want to do
a little quick personal thing which is
you know when we walk we where we look
is where we move that's our intent
so when I was a young writer at UCL I
was very insecure didn't know if I had
what it took don't come from wealthy
parents I was on student aid and I
really have this idea of I need to know
if this is gonna work out for me because
if it isn't I'm going to law school and
so I I made a promise to myself that
within one year I was gonna sell a
script and 13 months later I sold a
pitch to Ridley Scott and I was willing
to say that counts and then really said
he was making the movie his front page a
variety and I was getting all of these
offers to write projects high-profile
projects for money at least for me I
didn't know people made that kind of
money I don't come from money but what I
realized is these weren't the kind of
things I wanted to be writing they were
the kind of movies I'd want to see but I
don't want to write these it's not it's
not creatively fulfilling I want to be
doing these and I was stupid or naive or
both enough to call my agent and say hey
I'm getting all these offers but I
really want these kind of offers I want
to be doing this and my agent took a
really long pause I think just to figure
out how of a nicest way to say this but
in her own very very sweet way what she
said is if you wanted that career why
didn't you write the spec scripts that
get you that career because you wrote
the spec scripts to get you this career
and she said this is your career so
you're gonna follow this career for five
years and you were going to nail it
knock it out of the park and after five
years if you want to start talking about
how you might change the industry
perception of you and how you might want
to bend your career over there we can do
that but if I'm representing you for the
next five years this is your career
because that's the career you've
launched so there was a really important
question if that's the correct one why
did I write a script that launches this
career and the answer was I never asked
myself what kind of career I wanted my
intent was to launch a career and I
achieved that my intent wasn't to launch
the career I most wanted and I worked
with writers routinely who have careers
who come to me and they're like I want
to change my
career I want to change what I'm known
for I wouldn't change a trajectory of my
career and they have very similar
stories so it's it takes a lot of effort
a lot of training a lot of hard work to
launch a career if you're going to do
that you might as well do it in service
of a career you most want or at least
that ought to be your plan a you know at
some point someone can say I've done all
this training I've done all this
dedication this is the career I want
it's just not happening for me maybe
there is a career a more suited for
maybe there's a different kind of
writing maybe it's not what I most love
doing but maybe I can make a living
doing that that's Plan B and there
certain is certainly our writers will do
that at some point they're like this
isn't working let me go to plan B but
for so many people like myself I just
started with Plan B and and for a lot of
writers maybe they would have gotten
what they most wanted if they went there
so that's why it's so important I
believe to start with what is the career
you most want and why because I think
you owe it to yourself to do what's
required to have to give yourself a shot
at that okay now the question becomes
you know the career you most want how do
you deserve that career then of course
it is writing the right scripts but what
people have to realize is it's not a
good script it's not a great script it's
an exceptional script so let me tell you
a true story Bruce Springsteen run the
greatest rock and roll gods of all time
he talks a lot about his life in the
Netflix special but there's a
documentary also if you can watch on the
making of Born to Run oh that sounds
good is really if you're if you if
you're like me and your nerd of the
creative process it's it's it's amazing
so Bruce Springsteen when the most
talented musicians to ever walk the
earth
dedicated you know all his friends are
going to college and start you know jobs
and starting families he was just
playing music for free or for no money
he was just all in on having he want to
be a rock star and he was all in and he
was mega talented and
got a record deal which almost nobody
got and they promoted it and they market
it and they made radio stations play as
music this is the 1970s there's no
internet
there's no Spotify there's no iTunes if
radio stations don't play your music no
one knows who you are they don't want to
play an unknown person but Columbia
Records could say do you want the new
Fleetwood Mac album do you want the
right that you're gonna play Bruce
Springsteen this number of times and
we're gonna have people listening to
make sure so all of that and the record
came out and it bombed now I always have
someone close to me he's mad they're
like it was brilliant you know I'm not
saying it wasn't artistically brilliant
I'm saying it commercially bombed Bruce
says that and he got something very
people to get in the record business a
second chance and he poured heart and
soul and he knew the second album that
was this certain or he was given up his
dream and the second album came out and
it bombed and God smiled on him because
you got a third chance and that third
album was born to run his first two
albums sold 42,000 copies born to run
ten million copies born run is
considered one the five greatest albums
of all time
he became and remains a rock god in the
1970s if you want to be famous there's
two ways to do it be on the cover of
People magazine or Newsweek magazine
he's gonna cover both in the same week
oh wow so here's the question and this
is the question that anyone who once you
know the career you most want how you
deserve it here's my question for you
what was different about Bruce
Springsteen's third album than the first
two albums mmm the most popular guess I
get is luck gotta be in the right place
at the right time catch lightning in a
bottle luck is an excuse born run was a
transcendent album it would have been
goober successful if it was released
five years earlier five years later if
it was released today it is transcendent
it's not luck yes you can write an
amazing script and if you're not in the
right place at the right time it may not
sell or get made that is true but if you
write a transcendent script you will
launch a career people want to work with
you they'll want to hear your pitches
don't want to staff you so it's not luck
the other answer I get is that he found
his voice he found his authentic voice
no you go to the first two albums and it
is his authentic voice it is Bruce you
hear that talent and that voice and that
melancholy and that aching and that
strength it he had his voice hone in
those first year albums so he he didn't
find his voice he didn't get lucky so
what is the difference and the answer is
Neal Landau and Bruce Springsteen talks
about it in this documentary Neal Landau
was a reporter for The Rolling Stone who
was big fan of those first two albums
and came on board as a producer and he
produced Bruce Springsteen's third album
and they talked about it in his
documentary both Neal and Bruce what
Neil and Al did was he changed Bruce
Springsteen's process evolve Bruce
Springsteen's process just that much and
changing this process because process is
how we create product changing the
process that much can be the difference
between a failure and being a rock god
or a failure in being an a-list writer I
see this with writers they're like this
close and so it's changing your process
it's evolving your process and almost
every a-list writer I know will say
there was someone in my life a manager a
showrunner a producer who helped me see
a different creative way of doing this
an evolved way of doing it changing your
process so that is so key for someone
who's like this is the career I want the
way I deserve it is to write just
exceptional scripts okay how do I write
exceptional scripts well talent you know
make sure that you have properly trained
yourself to create characters and
dialogue that are compelling compelling
conflict I did all this in a film
courage video the essential tools so you
can go back and watch that video then
often the missing piece and this is what
I do and might I have a three workshop
series in the first two workshops are
really teaching those skill sets and the
third workshop is all about process and
it's all about evolving your process
there's a lot of things I do in that
workshop
I'll share one with your audience I'll
share one specific tool and just to be
clear this is this is just one of like
15 tools that are really important but
here's one and one of the tools that I
teach is the clarity index and so what
it it's a very simple tool when you are
trying to design and execute an
exceptional script so it's not following
the rules it's not paradigm driven it's
not predictable it's not character
serving preordained plot points but
you're trying to write a script like
Russian doll or Breaking Bad Pilar
Marvel's mrs. myzel or fleabag or we
could go on and on and on then you're
creating something original and I
guarantee you there's going to be at
least one or more times in that process
that's gonna get really hard and it's
going to be really difficult to figure
something out how do I motivate the
character to do this or how do I solve
this dilemma that the characters in or
the there's there's a wide range of
structural design issues that can be
really challenging every writer goes
through that so when you're trying to
solve a really challenging creative
problem I ask people to think about a
spectrum between one and ten and one is
I have no idea in the world how to do
this I have I don't know the answer I
don't even know where to start looking
I am completely lost and a 10 is when
you can concisely and precisely answer
it when people hear that answer they're
like yes you know if you go back and
look at the creative integration video
for film courage like their intuitive
instinct just goes yes and their
conceptual analytical brain goes yes
so a 10 is that is that answer and you
can say it the more we have to talk the
less we know you can say it concisely
and precisely and in a room everyone's
just gonna look at you and go yes so
that's a 10 and a 1 is no idea I don't
even know where to look so a 5 is like I
have a sense the ideas over here I think
it's sort of shaped this way but I don't
know what it is you know an eight is I
know the answer but I can't precisely
tell it to you if you let me talk as I
talk it's in there somewhere maybe you
can help me find it because I know it's
here but I can't I don't know exactly
where it exactly what it that's like an
eight you know a three would be I don't
know the answer but I have a pretty good
sense I should look in this direction
okay so this is the spectrum so the
first thing that I want to train people
to do is know where you are know where
you are and understand that if you're
trying to write a script that can change
your life that can launch your career or
take I work a lot right now I used to
work with writers who were trying to
launch their careers I don't do that
anymore I now work I do that in my
workshops but one on one I primarily
work with people who've been staffed on
shows who are trying to get to the next
level so I tell them inherently you're
going to be at a1 or a2 in the beginning
here's one of the most important things
what is your relationship with being at
a low number a lot of writers get really
stressed they get anxious it's very
uncomfortable you're working on a script
Jack if I can't solve this problem the
script doesn't work and I have no idea
how to solve this problem I've been
thinking about it for three days and I
the the example I give that I can relate
to is whenever I park in a large parking
garage I can never find my car so if I'm
walking through a large parking garage I
know my car is there but I can't find it
it gets frustrating but imagine if I
don't even know if I drove the car there
now imagine if I don't even know if I
have a car because when you're at a low
number on this clarity spectrum you
don't know the answer you don't know if
there is an answer and if there is an
answer you don't know if you're gonna
find it you may not be able to find it
there's no guarantee and that freaks
people out and they get very stressed
and uncomfortable but we know about
human beings is there's an automatic
part of our brain
wants to when we get stressed and
freaked out longs to soothe and comfort
ourselves and we have different ways of
doing it here's a whole bunch of really
destructive ways writers soothe
themselves when they're really freaked
out about a really tough problem you
have no idea if they can figure it out
or not unfortunately I can relate to
almost all of these strategies so one
strategy is to convince yourself it's
not a problem I'm overthinking this now
I'm making a mountain out of a molehill
this is no one else is even gonna see
this problem and then that calms you
down
lets you keep writing and then down the
road when you give the script to someone
that you trust you're gonna find out
that this was a glaring problem for them
and the whole script doesn't work so
you're just kicking the can down the
road one of my favorite strategies was
to then another possible strategy is to
say now it's a really big problem it's
gotta be solved and then they come up
with a kind of decent answer that's like
a five on the clarity spectrum and I
convinced myself it's a ten I have an
answer that kind of works but it's not a
really great answer and I'm like perfect
once again you're gonna get your
comeuppance when people read your scrap
people you trust because you didn't
solve the problem and now there are
mistakes that people will make is
they'll say there just is no solution to
this problem that's why no one's done
the TV show I hear people say us all the
time like if Breaking Bad didn't exist
you could I could see someone saying
that's why no one's done a TV show about
a guy who cooks crystal meth because
there's no way to care about that guy no
one wants to spend time with a guy who
cooks crystal meth crystal meth is a
scourge of the universe or you know no I
have this great idea of doing a spy
story where the protagonists are Russian
spies they're Russian spies they coming
to America they were KGB agents they
speak perfect English they have kids
they pretend to be married and they
undermine the American Way and
everyone's like oh that's an interesting
concept and then it's like yeah but no
one cares about these people where the
stakes are gonna get caught oh no
they're gonna get caught killing
Americans undermining the American Way
they're the enemy well of course that
guy figured out how to do that script
and the Americans changed as
not only did he sell that script he was
a showrunner in year two and that that
has won so many Emmys and Best Drama and
my point is any script that's gonna
change your life has something about it
that's really hard to figure out and so
what a lot of writers will do is they'll
say yeah banana for three or four days
or a week there is no solution that's
why no one's done a show like this or
maybe there's a solution that someone
smarter than me can figure out and they
just put that script away there are so
many writers who had an instinct for
something unique and special and amazing
have something really difficult to
figure out struggled with it and then
just put that in a drawer that script
would have changed their life but it
went into a drawer the reality is the
writers who we all admire the writers
who create amazing shows David Chase
really wanted to do a show about what
it's like to feel like your mom is just
crushing your life out of you it's like
she's killing you but you can't escape
her because you're Roman Catholic it's
your mom
and he couldn't figure out how to do
that with stakes took him two years he
talked about this two years to figure it
out he finally figured out a little
project called The Sopranos so the point
being how many people have a Sopranos or
Breaking Bad or a fleabag it's just in
their drawer and it took David the
difference between David chase and most
writers or Jinju Cohen and I think she
said took her like 11 months to figure
out how to do and solve some of the
problems and orange is a new plaque the
difference between Genji Cohen and David
Chase isn't that they don't start at a
low number it isn't that they struggle
it isn't that they're lost it isn't they
go down a lot of dead alleys or you know
blind alleys that don't go anywhere
that's that that's not what's different
for them what's different is they don't
give up and they have a process to get
to attend but they don't give up so many
writers give up they they they
rationalize away the problem they
rationalize that a okay solutions a
brilliant solution or they just say well
that's why no one did can you know I
have this great concept but that's why
no one's done it because it can't work
or the classic I need a vacation from
this I'll
put it in a drawer working something
else and I'll go back to this and then
they acquired Warfel so what's really
important is to train yourself to expect
to be at a low number and to relax into
the unknown to be okay and then to have
a process to start moving up instead of
trying to find the solution start
brainstorming possible ways of
approaching the solution always be
looking for options always be
brainstorming possibilities that's the
way because when you're trying to find
the right solution you're so constricted
and that judgmental part is coming in
and throwing things away like well
that's not perfect but if you're
brainstorming options if you're just
brainstorming options for ways to find
options then you can relax that critical
judgmental mind and you can start
wandering and then you start moving up
and you start to have a sense and an
idea and you start to move up and most
writers will stop at a nine a lot of
writers don't know what a ten feels like
and so they're always stopping at a nine
so one of the things that I do in the
workshops is I will bring in a creative
problem that a writer I worked with had
and how this was their first idea and
how to solve it and it clearly isn't
very good and then how they got all the
way here to a really good solution but
it was like a nine and then I give them
the ten and you can feel the difference
I can't do this here because I have
permission to do it in the workshops but
people can go through film courage
videos there's a lot of great writers
talking and sharing their stories and
what I would be looking for is so there
are writers are going to talk about how
they got in business they're gonna talk
about this project they're gonna talk
about how this came together and all
that's really interesting it can be
educational and inspiring but what I
would really pay attention to is a
writer and I know that this exists in a
lot of the interviews is look for a
writer who's talking about a really
difficult creative process or creative
problem they're trying to solve and then
they give what the actual solution was
and you'll feel it
you'll feel like in so few words they
just nailed it so you need to know what
a 10 feels like to hold yourself to 10
so to sort of wrap this all together
I'll share a true story my wife has a
cousin whose dream was to be a baseball
player and he was the best high school
baseball player in the eastern half the
United States and long story short when
all his friends went to college he went
to the Yankees he was 18 and he went to
the Yankees but in the minor league
system the the like triple-a and he was
an Adonis i man amongst boys he broke
all the batting home run records
Defensive Player of the Year and this
guy was going to be one of the greatest
baseball players of all time and a
pretty young age the at a pretty young
age the Yankees brought him up to the
majors and he was playing with his
heroes and he was just striking out
striking out he couldn't hit the ball so
there that's ok the game a batting coach
a psychology coach couldn't hit the ball
so he put him back down the minor at
home run home run home run brought him
back up to the major strikeout strike
gut that's ok and they just kept doing
this for like four years and they
eventually caught him another team the
Cleveland Indians picked him up same
thing same cycle they cut him another
team with the three teams same thing in
the minor leagues broke records in the
major league he could not hit the ball
and then that was over he was 27 years
old and it was over now he saved his
money he went to architect school met a
wonderful woman they're married have
kids he's very happy but here's an inch
I didn't learn this whole thing because
it was with the metal wedding and we
were walking from point A to point B
which meant walking over some grass he
wouldn't do it he walked a mile out of
his way to not go on grass and his
wife's like yeah he won't walk on grass
we don't have grass on our house he will
never walk on grass as an entire life
and I'm like I gotta have to hear this
story
central context what is this all about
sense memory it reminds him walking on
grass reminds about baseball and it
reminds him of his dream that he can't
ever have they just have walks on grass
so I asked him what's the difference
between hitting the best minor-league
pitch and an average major league pitch
and he looked at me and he said that
that's the difference and writers don't
understand
that doesn't seem like a lot but when
that's what stands between you and your
dream that's a lot and I have writers
that are sent to me by agents and
managers who are this close and on the
clarity spectrum they can get to a nine
they think it's a ten me no one's gonna
push that extra mile they don't you know
if you think you've ran 26.2 miles
you're like I've done the marathon and
you can stop but what if you've only
gone 25 miles that's what a really good
manager will do for you is they will
tell you this script is really good it's
not yet exceptional you got to make it
that much better because nobody does
that on their own because they don't
realize it could be that much better you
know when I was starting out the
greatest gift my manager gave me is he
held me to a standard I didn't think I
could hit and he said I know you can hit
that standard I don't know if he really
thought that or not but I needed to hear
that
and so the clarity spectrum is not
making the mistakes at the smaller
number yeah and as you go through life
and you you watch film courage videos or
you know writer podcasts or you go to
events where you hear writers talk you
will hear writers talk about creative
problems or if they talk about a
creative prom but they didn't talk about
solution try to social-media them or go
up them after the event and just say hey
I'm a writer and you were talking about
in the script you were struggling with
this I'm really curious like how did you
what was your process how did you get to
an answer what was that answer in my I
did it all I just all the time with
writers they're usually excited to share
this you know they usually people come
up to them it's like how do I get it
agent well you read my script but if you
approach a writer and you're like I just
want to learn what your process was and
what was the solution they'll share it
with you and if you do that pay
attention to how few of work how few
words they use to give the answer and
how when you hear that answer how it
makes you feel like there's a tuning
fork inside you where you're like yeah
yeah yeah no that's it that's brilliant
and that's what a 10 feels like and you
know what a 10 feels like then you'll
know when you're not
there you had talked about in the last
film courage interview that you read
rewrites the memoir by Neil Simon yeah
and I just briefly skimmed the book on
Amazon and he kind of talked about the
same thing he in terms of being unhappy
working in LA on a television show and
he was like if I don't I think his quote
was if I don't start writing a Broadway
play soon I wouldn't inevitably become a
permanent part of the West Coast
typography this very thought of that
jump-started me to my desk so butBut do
you think it he was thirty I think when
he was talking about that do you think
most writers know they they just kind of
think about that same thing that you
like I've got to get signed I've got to
get yeah you know and and how do they
even know that this is the wrong genre
or type of writing job for them you see
might not so I mistake that I made and I
think I made a lot of stupid mistakes
this mistake I don't beat myself up too
much because they think this is a pretty
understandable mistake and I see writers
make this which is just because you love
a certain TV show or a certain movie or
a certain genre choosing just because
you love a certain TV show or a movie or
a certain genre doesn't mean you love
writing it it might I mean you know
fleabag is your your all-time favorite
TV show and you could write something
like that you might love it you might
not so what I suggest is especially if
you're new it's the instead of picking
this is the kind of writer I'm gonna be
play with it and write 10 or 15 pages of
this kind of a thing in Santa Fe the
page of this kind of thing Tennant and
don't worry if it's great don't worry
about the engine and the concepts and
all that just see what is my experience
in writing these pages just experiment
it's like being a young kid in an attic
and you try on different clothes and you
pretend to be different people what what
person what type of writing really
excited you I'll tell you one of the
things that I have routinely see when
I'll work with a writer
you know we always start with an entry
in an initial kind of interview
conversation and there and the writer
will always say you know this is the
kind of stuff I write this is what I
think's in my wheelhouse this is the
stuff that I would suck at and I always
make them try to do what they think
they'd suck at like again not an entire
spread you know maybe just a couple days
an assignment it's not that in common
that someone when they do this it's like
holy [ __ ] it's so good and I loved it
and I've seen writers who've had this
career and they play around with what
they know they wouldn't be too good at
and they go on and have huge careers not
saying that's always the case
so experiment sort of you know just like
maybe when someone's a young person
they're not really sure who they want to
be in a long-term Alysha maybe you date
around and you you meet different people
and your date different people maybe
date people you wouldn't think of dating
just to see what the experience is like
the same date different kinds of writing
but yeah it's really it's it is uncommon
it is common that writers will have a
career and then discover that's not what
I want to be doing that's very common I
mean just talk to agents or managers
they have a lot of good friends or
agents they they hear this all the time
you